what's going on guys this is Robin we
are back with Thor and this title is not
even clickbait this story is boss check
this out so this story basically takes
place immediately after Banner of War
now for those of you guys who never saw
the video that we did for the banner of
War Series this was basically a big
fight between Thor and the Incredible
Hulk Thor as the all father facing off
against the Incredible Hulk who ends up
becoming Titan Hulk over the course of
the fight and then there's like another
caveat which gets even better right like
literally Thor becomes the Hulk it's so
cool but the thing about this is this is
why Thor's kind of mulling over what had
happened because one of the things that
had taken place in this fight is that
when Thor became the Hulk he of course
basically became mindless and in the
process destroyed the entirety of the
bifrost bridge now this is an important
thing because of course the bifrost
bridge is the way in and out of Asgard
now for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar when it comes to Asgard and
the bifrost and Marvel Comics it's just
one method of teleportation that Marvel
often likes to play up the idea that the
bifrost is really the only way in and
out of Asgard it's the only official way
the real quality here is there's all
kinds of portals and means to get in and
out of Asgard depending on what your
level of power is but what this does is
it really leads Thor to kind of ask the
question whether or not he is as capable
of a leader as he truly believed he was
now a lot of this is Thor kind of
comparing himself to Odin because there
wasn't really any instance where Odin
had engaged in a series of actions that
basically would lead to the potential
ruin of Asgard itself Thor's done that
multiple times when he became the herald
of Galactus this instance of destroying
the bifrost and cutting Asgard off but
lest we forget Thor's kind of getting
caught up in his own feelings here
because the reality is like characters
like the man Gog exist because of Odin
for those of you guys who don't know who
the mangog is he's like the one thing
Odin feared the most because mangog
could never actually be defeated that he
could just be held at Bay and when that
guy came calling all as Guardians fell
before that guy like it was it was
impossible to defeat the man God like
literally Odin would just be in his
throne room and somebody would come
running in saying oh my God man God's
here and then Odin just craps his pants
out of fear like that's literally what
we were talking about when it came to
that guy he was dope but the funny thing
is that in the midst of all this Loki
appears now of course Loki being here is
to kind of make fun of Thor a little bit
to kind of give him a hard time but at
the same time Thor actually needs Loki
and the reason why is because he
basically contacts him asking him like
do you have a means for us to repair the
bifrost bridge because you deal with
magic and the entirety of the bridge was
made with magic and Thor's capabilities
are not on the same level as Odin that
yes Thor is technically in possession of
the Odin Force but the way in which Odin
used it is drastically different than
the way in which Thor uses it now the
other part about this and this is one of
the coolest parts of the story Donald
Blake so one of the things to know here
for those of you guys who are new to the
Thor Mythos Donald Blake when he was
first introduced to Marvel Comics was
like Thor's version of Clark Kent over
the years in Marvel they've toyed with
the idea of Donald Blake to the point
that in fact Donna Blake and Thor were
physically separated and they were two
distinctly different beings in more
recent years Marvel and did that right
so you still have basically Thor turning
into Donald Blake and then Donald Blake
turning into Thor what we ended up
learning here is that whenever Thor is
walking around as himself the Donald
Blake Persona gets whisked away to like
some far-off imaginary place but because
Thor had not changed into Donald Blake
for so long Donald Blake literally went
crazy and he envied the life that Thor
had and so by some strange Manner and
means he ends up basically escaping and
then goes on a Warpath killing all kinds
of asgardians ultimately he's captured
by really Loki and Thor and then the
punishment for Donald Blake is left to
Loki and when Thor asks the question
what was it that you did with Donald
Blake the response of Loki is you don't
want to know what Loki had actually done
is he had hidden Donald Blake down below
Asgard in a place that no one can see
not even Sif who now has the powers of
Heimdall to see everything in existence
across the entirety of the universe and
down in that tomb right down and that
just really crappy place Donald Blake is
strapped to a bed and poisoned from the
the teeth of a snake constantly drips in
his eyes and it'll be that way for all
eternity now that's going to become a
major focal point as we get towards the
end of this but of course with what Loki
ends up saying is of course Thor you
know I'll help you with the bifrost
bridge and that kind of thing once they
get to its location what Loki realizes
is the bifrost bridge can't just be
easily reassembled that even someone
like Doctor Strange despite the fact
that at this moment that he's dead if he
were alive would not be able to easily
clear it up and the reason why is
because while the bifrost bridge is
largely composed of magic and whatnot
the truth about this is that it would be
like demolishing a building and then
trying to build a building on top of all
the rubble it doesn't work that way you
gotta clear the rubble out and then you
have to build a new building and that's
literally what's going on here that
there are forms of magic and mysticism
that were used to build the bifrost and
those forms of magic are still there so
what literally has to happen here is all
that magic has to be removed eliminated
wiped out and then replaced with new
magic to build a new bridge but the
problem with this is that they don't
know how long it's going to take because
the bifrost bridge was built long before
Thor and Loki even showed up on the
scene right like it's been around for an
exceedingly long amount of time so as
far as Loki's concerned it could take
like 10 months it could take 10 000
years have no idea how long it would
take to rebuild this thing but what he
says is there are other forms of travel
in and out of Asgard if what you want to
do is visit the other Realms and make
sure that our role of keeping them safe
is still intact they haven't fallen into
chaos or anything like that and so when
Loki opens a portal to what would
traditionally be basically Limbo what it
does is it leads to like dark Hoth the
dark demon just showing up out of
nowhere and it's one of those crazy
things because there is a reason for why
this happens right now we will cover the
reason for why he jumps out of here in a
different video because it's just a
little too complex to go into here it's
part of the Venom Mythos what's going on
with Donnie Kate's Venom run so again
we'll probably cover that later on this
week so keep your eye out for that but
basically dark Hoth just kind of shows
up here and where literally he just like
emits this giant growl and Thor and like
Sif start to prepare you know battle
armaments the responsive Loki is what I
mean we don't know if we need to fight
this guy like he's literally from a
demonic realm maybe his whole stance
right whoever this being is because they
don't know it's dark Hoth but they're
like whoever this being is maybe he's
here and like the roar is a sign of
friendship and when he's like literally
smacks Loki like attacks Loki Thor gives
this hilarious response where he says ah
yes the hand of friendship
that's the great thing about this guy he
knows how to reach out and touch someone
so the thing about this is that as as
literally this guy starts ripping away
that's what's basically a symbiote
that's attached to him that that's when
Thor realizes it's darkhof now a little
bit of history about this guy he's not
overly interesting and in fact we
haven't seen him since 1991 in Marvel
Comics like he's just been gone ever
since the old Excalibur stories but
basically he was at one point a guy
named Desmond Pitt and the idea behind
this is that he was a friend of the
Fantastic Four but when he was working
for NASA he actually learned that Dr
Doom had sent latvirians to infiltrate
NASA and when he did that he of his own
accord infiltrated the latvirians and
then eventually met Doctor Doom but once
Doom realized that he was a traitor Dr
Doom broke every bone in this guy's body
and then re-healed the bones using
promethium which is actually a material
a kind of uh kind of magic of sorts from
the realm of limbo so he literally
infused this guy with demonic energy and
then sent him off to the realm of limbo
and that's basically where he's been
ever since and he's kind of ruled it off
and on and different things like that
he's had he has a pretty tortured past
what's crazy about this is you see those
two little antenna on the top of his
head those things can emit concussive
blast or they can shoot Hellfire and
that's literally what happens this guy
shows up here on the scene and then
immediately attacks all of these guys
and just starts blasting them with
Hellfire now under normal circumstances
this kind of thing wouldn't necessarily
harm Thor right like a being with a
magical attack depending on their level
of power but lest we forget when it
comes to the realm of limbo and even the
other Hell locations you're talking
about power and fire that can kill Gods
so while it doesn't necessarily destroy
Thor it is enough to harm him relatively
severely the bigger problem with this is
that he ultimately ends up taking off
and when he does what he ends up leaving
behind is kind of a symbiote form of
sorts and when that happens we basically
end up seeing Venom emerge now this is
one of the things I want you to keep in
mind here because this will become
important as we get further into this
we'll make sense of all this stuff by
the time we get to the end so I'm not
going to leave you hanging on
information don't worry it'll all come
together but Venom shows up here
basically telling Thor his name's Eddie
Brock and he's like I haven't seen you
in a long time you look different right
like it's it's you look a little bit
different now of course Thor kind of has
a whole new wardrobe and everything
because he is literally the all-father
of Asgard now but this guy right dark
Hoth just shows up and starts attacking
all these different people and Asgard
and what Eddie Brock tells him is that
at the moment dark Hoth is actually
infused with a baby symbiote and that
this symbiote doesn't quite understand
what's going on here a really good
similarity here to understand is like
how the Carnage symbiote is The
Offspring of Venom that's literally what
this is technically the Symbiote that's
attached to darkov is The Offspring of
another symbiote called Bedlam again
that's all part of the Venom Mythos and
we'll make a separate video making sense
of all that stuff but then thing about
this is that what what Venom literally
tells Thor is because the Symbiote has
taken hold of darkov and is now using
his mystical energy you have a Godly
Godly powered imbued symbiote that
doesn't understand what's going on but
it's learning its power as it uses that
power so it's like a Godly child just
throwing a temper tantrum in Asgard God
only knows what it is they're gonna do
so while you do have a fight that takes
place between dark Hoth and Venom that
initially Venom's defeated Thor is able
to kind of bring a bring a momentary
quell to the fight but one of the things
to remember about symbiotes is they can
copy things right they can literally
take on different physical appearances
and in fact they can conjure things
using their own symbiote form and so
what Venom tells uh tells Thor is that
in this instance if Thor's gonna fight
this guy he has to be aware that this
symbiote is just copying the things that
it sees and literally what's the most
powerful thing that this symbiote sees
right now it's Thor with mjolnir and so
literally what this guy does is he
conjure his own mjolnir out of his own
symbiote form that's infused with
demonic power it's the antithesis of
malnir essentially it's pretty nuts and
so the fight between him and Thor is
pretty knocked down drag out man the
fight is so extreme and the Magical
energy imbued to this guy and his hammer
is so extreme that as they're fighting
and as their hammers hit it actually
starts to melt the metal that was used
to rebuild the hammer of Thor hits his
hammer starts falling apart and where
you have like Eddie Brock and you have
Sif that try to jump in there's only so
much they can do by all standard of
measurement Thor's being overwhelmed
here and where Thor literally tries to
chime in too or really try to talk
directly to Desmond Pitts and say hey
man you gotta come back you gotta pull
it together in all reality he's kind of
overtaken there's no ability to
communicate with that guy directly and
so realize in the situation and that the
only way for Thor and Venom to defeat a
demonic God that is one part symbiote
and one part God is for they themselves
to become one part symbiote one one part
god so literally Venom bonds himself to
Thor and when he does that they become
like the god in Black literally Thor
becomes Venom and I or I guess maybe
Venom becomes slow whatever you want to
call it but I love what Donnie Cates is
doing here because like literally in the
last story arc Thor became the Hulk now
we get to see Thor become venom and I
love these kind of stories that Marvel
does where like somebody takes on a form
that they that you don't normally see
and the potential power that comes along
with it ever since the original King and
black story The Power of venom has been
bolstered several times over he's way
more powerful than he used to be he's
stronger he's faster he's more
intelligent so you take those heightened
abilities and then you apply them to
Thor and it amplifies them even further
and so now Thor's able to actually hold
his own directly against darkoth and is
actually able to for the most part
defeat this guy but the reason why this
comes off is that because when it comes
to someone like Venom we'll use him as
an example here venom has been around
for a long long time right he's fought
Spider-Man over and over and over again
and Spider-Man has sound and Spider-Man
has used fire but because of both his
experience as well as his current set of
powers those kinds of things don't
necessarily apply to Venom anymore he
has ways to get around the effects of
sound of Sonic's in you know disturbing
the Symbian he has ways to get around
fire in terms of disturbing the symbia
right like in more recent stories the
Symbiote has been forced to endure fire
in order to do whatever it needed to do
hence building up a tolerance to it
right it doesn't mean he's immune to it
but it means he's more capable of
dealing with it than he was before the
other problem here though is that with
darkhoth this symbiote's brand new it's
operating on Instinct so it's afraid of
fire and it's afraid of Sonic's it's the
Venom symbiote from 30 years ago in
Marvel Comics and so literally what it
does is that in this kind of Victory it
flees the body of darkov and it takes
off right it literally bails out as fast
as it possibly can but what ends up
happening here is that the hammer is of
course left behind and that's when Venom
starts acting a little strange here
because literally it picks up the hammer
and the response of Thor is what are you
doing right like I've realized ever
since you've been here you're hiding
something right like there's like
something about you is not quite right
and that's when we find out it is Eddie
Brock but it's not Eddie Brock it's
actually Meridius now for those of you
guys who are unfamiliar with the Venom
the the Venom stories that were going on
right now right clarify this for all of
you guys
so the current set of events that are
taking place in venom at the moment is
that we had the king and black storyline
the introduction of null the Symbiote
god the guy who created all the
Symbiotes and controls all the symbias
eventually he was defeated by Venom and
then Venom assumed the role of King in
Black so now he has control of all the
Symbiotes and he operates in that way
what ended up happening is that there
came a point when he basically died
right Eddie Brock ended up being killed
and he woke up in what was called The
Garden of time right The Hive Garden
technically is the name but what he
ended up encountering were these
different symbiotes where you had like
wild and you had like Bedlam and you had
all these different things Meridius
seemed to be the one that was leading
all of them what we ended up learning
here is that all these different
symbiotes that Eddie Brock met were
basically him at different points in
time and that Meridius is quote unquote
his final form or at least that seems to
be the case and so Meridius is the most
powerful version of the Symbiote or
Venom that we've seen to date and so
literally the thing about him is and he
explains it here exceedingly well he
says I am Meridius the Edward Brock of
your future on a mission to save mod the
past is set in stone it must be but the
future can be changed I know this time
period Thor I know you've seen your
future your fate if you could turn back
what is to come wouldn't you at least
try now of course what Meridius is
talking about here is what what uh
Donnie case has been foreshadowing which
is like Thanos showing back up with the
infinity gauntlets and Thor's hammer and
like the Destroyer armor while leading
an army of zombies we have no idea what
that means but it sounds amazing and
everybody at Marvel is excited to see
what happens
because it's going to be really really
dope but Meridius basically his Venom
ends up turning on Thor and initially he
gets the upper hand on it right because
Meridius is extremely powerful he's
extremely capable but one of the things
that Thor says is that he's largely been
holding back especially in his fight
against darkhoth because he knew
something weird was going on when it
came to Venom and he really just didn't
want to reveal his whole hand and so as
he's facing off against Meridius
literally using lightning which Meridius
himself despite how powerful he is is
not able to withstand light lightning
fire for any prolonged period of time
and literally overwhelms Meridius with
his lightning like just attacking him
with just this constant Onslaught and so
of course it basically melts the hammer
The Last Vestige of this Bedlam symbiote
which just disappears into the ground
and then Meridius basically takes off
right like that Meridius form ends up
bailing out and so where the Symbiote
seeps into the ground the response of
Thor is okay so like what do we do here
and where the answer is given while I
mean anxious it's seep into the ground
like there's nothing down there the
response of Loki is yeah yeah there's
there's nothing down there nothing we
need to worry about only for us to find
out that what actually happened is the
Symbiote seeped below ground down into
the cavern where Donald Blake is being
held tortured by The Serpent and his
poison teeth and the Symbiote merges
with Donald Blake which means now Donald
Blake who had gone on a war path and who
had killed all the asgardians is
re-emerging yet again and God only knows
what this guy is going to end up doing
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
Bruce